servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe ich vor
einigen tagen auf twitter gebeten mir
fragen zu stellen die herausfinden was
bisher noch niemand von meinen
zuschauern über mich weiß und hebt mit
fünf fragen ausgesucht und wer durch
dementsprechend im heutigen video fünf
dinge mitteilen die er bisher noch nicht
ich wusste im hintergrund seht ihr ein
dragon escape gameplay
ich hoffe es ist für eine einzige person
draußen interessant wahrscheinlich nicht
aber vielleicht finden wir irgendwann
diese eine person die es interessiert
was ich hier zu erzählen aber wenn da
draußen bist kannst du bitte
kommentieren
die erste frage die wir beantworten
möchte stammt von louis xiii tesche
question was machst du wenn es
irgendwann mal kein youtube mehr geben
würde
ich glaube ich glaube erst mal wüsste
ich gar nicht wohin mit meiner zeit war
youtube doch eine sache ist die relativ
viel zeit in anspruch und theoretisch
jeden tag auch wenn ich es nicht mehr
schaffe jeden tag hochzuladen
sorry dafür ich arbeite daran dass
umzustellen wirklich am liebsten
wirklich jeden tag hochladen
aber so ein bisschen schwierig so sich
neue videos aus dem man jeden tag hoch
wie im hamsterrad ist wenn ihr versteht
was ich meine
was will ich machen ich war erstmal
überrascht glaube ich wusste nicht wohin
mit meiner zeit und dann glaube ich
würde ich mir als nächstes irgendwas
suchen auf das ich mich dann zu 100
konzentriere also was so etwas großes
wie youtube was so viel zeit in anspruch
nehmen glaublich weil ich gesehen habe
wie cool es ist viel viel zeit in eine
sache rein steckt und dann irgendwann
auch viel raus bekommt sei es jetzt
feedback sei es theoretisch auch die
kohle lieben verdient ist einfach cool
zu sehen dass man für das was man
reinsteckt was raus bekommt deswegen
will ich mir was anderes versuchen
vielleicht würde ich mich voll auf auf
kampfsport konzentrieren
das momentan sind neben weise wissen
wollte
das würde ich dann glaube ich richtig
machen mit 56 mal trainieren pro woche
darf vollgas geben alles klar frage 2
kommt von jackie zu kühlen
sie fragt was würdest du gerne können
was du nicht kannst und leute ich glaub
ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr das wusste man
hätte sich theoretisch erschließen
können was den dingen die ich bisher
mitgemacht habe ich bin fucking
unorganisiert den katastrophal
unorganisiert und oft auch und
diszipliniert und das ist so die dinge
die ich gerne ändern möchte mit selbst
wenn nichts mehr zu wünschen könnte so
ok ich möchte jetzt der typ sein können
wir das ja bis zu verändern und die
schraube ich will gerne mich maximal
selbst disziplinieren können das kann
ich momentan noch nicht leute ihr müsst
euch das gebe ich komme eigentlich jeden
tag zu jeder vorlesung zu spät
ich weiß nicht ich habe ein anderes hab
ich einfach eine andere anderes
zeitverständnis die zeit in meiner welt
in der ich lebe läuft langsamer als die
zeit in der welt in der alle anderen
leben versteht was ich meine
und so kommt es dazu dass ich mal 15
minuten zu spät bin nach meiner uhr bin
ich pünktlich aber bei denen dafür alles
viel schneller
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht was man da
machen soll
aber im ernst das würde ich gerne können
nächste frage von zielen wie würde ein
leben ohne youtube und die ganzen
freunde die du dadurch kennen gelernt
hast ablaufen
ok um die frage zu beantworten muss ich
erst mal ein bisschen weiter ausholen zu
allen themen was eigentlich der frage
selbst ist nicht drin stecken zwar bin
ich persönlich jemand der dieses wort
freund nicht häufig benutzt also wenn
ich das wort freund benutze dann
wirklich nur bei freunden bekannte sind
für mich keine freunde ein freund ist
für mich jemand auf den ich wirklich
zählen kann
denn nicht nur irgendein interesse an
mir hat mich irgendwie ausnutzen möchte
oder so das sind maximal bekannte aber
ich bin wirklich sehr sehr vorsichtig
mit dem wort freund also ich würde auch
momentan in meinem leben echt nicht
viele leute freunde nennen
ganz einfach weil mir das persönlich
wichtiges zu trennen zwischen freund und
bekannte und deswegen würde ich auch
sagen dass man gar nicht so viele
freunde über youtube bekommen hat ich
glaub tatsächlich in der regel sind das
eher bekannt also wirklich sein dass man
gar keine freunde gewonnen hat aber in
der regel sind das eher bekannt und
bekannt ist es auch gar nicht negativ
dass heißt ja nicht dass man die man an
es wünscht aber das heißt dass man diese
beziehung realistisch einschätzen kann
das heißt man macht sich selbst nichts
vor sondern die zeit so wie es ist
es ist schon cool die ganzen leute die
man kennenlernt ist schon echt cool muss
man sagen und es hat mir auch in vielen
situationen schon geholfen also oftmals
habe ich schon auf die leute da zählen
können
die ich darüber kennengelernt ob er mir
ausgeholfen wie würde mein leben
ablaufen ohne das alles keine ahnung
keine ahnung vielleicht will ich
trotzdem den ganzen tag im keller und
zimmer sitzen nur mit dem feinen
unterschied dass ich keine videos mehr
hochladen sondern einfach nur für mich
selbst zocke youtube ist schon gut muss
man sein
das hat mir wirklich schon viel gebracht
und ich mag momentan nicht darauf
verzichten auch wenn es viel zeit kostet
viel mühe teilweise ist und manchmal
auch den letzten nerv raubt manchmal es
trotzdem gut muss man sein aber um die
frage zu beantworten ich habe keine
ahnung ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
ist ablauf würde ich weiß nicht wo ich
jetzt wäre aber ich glaube dass die
letzten paar jahre nicht so cool gewesen
wären ohne youtube das muss man auf
jeden fall sagen youtube verdammt geile
zeit beschert und das ist achtung jetzt
emotionale dank im moment ist alles nur
wegen euch
könnte mir bitte noch ein abo tanzen
benutzen nicht gemacht denn eine sache
die ich zu allen sagen möchte die mich
nicht abonniert haben
die nächste frage ganz andere richtung
von knabe erfragt wie ging es dir wir
wie ging es dir bei deinem abiturprüfung
die ist jetzt echt schon eine weile her
also wir schreiben jetzt wir schreiben
das jahr 2016 ich hab im jahr 2012 mein
abitur prüfen wo man also ich war damals
echt jung mit 16 habe ich das mein abi
gemacht das wissen auch nicht viele
und ja ich hatte riesigen respekt davor
ich habe mir im vorfeld gedacht dass das
das schaff ich gar nicht dass es so ein
riesending das schaffe ich gar nicht wie
soll das gehen
und dann dann dachte ich mir so ok die
davor habe es auch irgendwie geschafft
ich hatte trotzdem riesigen schiss davor
diesen prüfungen auch wenn ich nicht so
der typ in der in der prüfung so richtig
angst hat oder so das ist er nicht mehr
denkt aber irgendwie da im vorfeld hatte
ich so wirklich bammel muss ich sagen
aber wie gesagt das team ok die von mir
und auch alle geschafft und jetzt
rückblickend
rückblickend muss man sagen dass die
prüfung hat schon relativ easy waren in
der prob prüfen selbst hatte ich keinen
schiss oder so ich habe einfach nur
geschrieben
das mag ich bin hier in der prüfen sitzt
ihr den bogen bekommt und dann das
adrenalin reinkriegt nach der ersten
aufgabe seit der solar tunnelblick der
wohl noch geradeaus 5000 ps vollgas mit
der dampflok und genau und die letzte
freie des heutigen tages von gina chon
du was würdest du in deinem
youtube-kanal verändern wenn du könntest
sehr schönes stück zum video talk dabei
ich möchte an meinem youtube-kanal
eigentlich verändern dass ich mich nie
nie nie nie nie nie nie erstellen möchte
ich mag einfach auf youtube am liebsten
so sein wie ich auch unter freunden bin
aber das ist echt schwer das ist gar
nicht so leicht wie man sich das
vielleicht denkt so als zuschauer
es ist nicht einfach so kommen ich setze
mich jetzt mal hin und mach meine witze
oder so sondern genau in dem moment wo
ich auf aufnehmen drücke verändert sich
meine persönlichkeit und stück wird als
ich bin wenn ich aufhöre auf jeden fall
das muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen
ein anderer mensch als privat was ist
ein anderer mensch
also ich bot sich mitte 40 und komme aus
zentralafrika offline
aber ich bin schon ein bisschen anders
drauf also man ist so vor der kamera
aufgedrehte und am allerliebsten wäre
ich vor der kamera genauso
die privat ja das wäre eine sache die
ich verändern würde also dass man quasi
immer zu 100% man selbst sein kann ohne
irgendeinen druck zu verspüren zu
verstellen und ansonsten würde ich am
liebsten die projekte die ich jetzt
schon im hinterkopf habe seit ewigkeiten
gerne mal starten
die zwei sachen vielleicht kommt da
demnächst was ich habe hier noch eine
weitere idee und blogger gleichmäßig
allem umsetzen aber das ist gar nicht so
leicht wenn man nebenbei noch studiert
ja das war so weit von diesem video
danke fürs zum stand haut rein macht es
gut und auch